So from the start of the pandemic, we've heard
the very general statement from a bunch of
different people who may or may not know what
they're talking about.
When it warms up, the virus is going to go
away.
And that suggests this kind of seasonality
to the virus.
And it implies the virus can't survive in
warmer weather.
And we don't actually have evidence of that
at this point.
And it appears to be sort of too simplistic
of a hypothesis.
But we do now have a very good paper that's
looking at the issue of temperature.
And it has found that there appears to be
a temperature and humidity combination present
in the places that have become sort of centers
of infection and spread.
The paper is called Temperature, Humidity
and Latitude Analysis to predict potential
spread and seasonality for covered 19.
It's a mouthful, but essentially what they
did is they looked at the cities that had
large amounts of communities spread and the
disease getting established.
And they looked at the climate data from those
cities to see is there a pattern where the
virus is taking hold versus where the virus
is not?
And indeed, check out what they found.
They found that there was significant community
spread in cities and regions along a narrow
East-West distribution, roughly along the
30 to 50 degree north corridor at similar
weather patterns consisting of average temperatures
of 5 to 11 degrees Celsius, combined with
low specific and absolute humidity.
Going on to say there's been a lack of significant
community establishment in expected locations
based only on population proximity and extensive
population interaction through travel.
So it's not just the temperature.
The temperature seems to be 5 to 11 see, which
is 41 to 52 Fahrenheit, but also specific
humidity ranges.
And in fact, places where you would expect
the virus to become established based on proximity
and travel.
It has not when the temperature and humidity
haven't matched up with these parameters.
So this tells us a few different things.
This tells us there may be a seasonal component
here, but it's more complex than just temperature.
It's temperature and humidity.
We conceivably could predict knowing what
the temperature and humidity ranges tend to
be as we get into spring and fall.
We could predict where over the coming months
we might see more and less spread on this
basis.
And this is one of the first more plausible
explanations, more specifically of why it
got so bad in Wuhan, Italy, Iran, South Korea
and in some specific other places, Seattle
as another example.
Again, these are correlations we don't yet
have a causal link.
This is just one study.
But this is also important to be considering
now.
Also important is the understanding that a
lot of the United States may enter those ranges
as we get into spring and summer.
So you have when the entire climate and temperature
thing, there's a few different elements to
it.
On one hand, there's the question of whether
the virus itself can survive as the temperature
goes up.
So sometimes when people say, well, when it
gets warmer, the virus is going to start to
die out or it's going to last less.
That's a question mark.
We don't know that to be the case when we
think of the flu.
It is true that in places like the northeast
of the U.S. where I live, the flu epidemics
are tend to go away when it gets warm.
But if you look at places that are warm year
round, they also still have flu transmission.
The flu seems to adapt to the warmer temperatures
in those areas.
So the question of whether Cauvin, 19 and
the bug that the virus that causes it can
survive in warmer temperatures.
That's one question.
When it gets warmer, people also tend to be
outside more and more spread out on average
than inside in office buildings and in close
proximity.
The think that's another factor.
But if we're self isolating, socially distancing
and working from home, does that make a difference?
But then lastly, is this new issue of the
actual temperature and humidity ranges at
which the virus is more transmissible, more
easily being transmitted?
The bad news about this study, even though
it shows a possible season seasonal component,
is that a lot of that belt is going to be
including much of the United States with that
optimal criteria.
So the odds that it simply goes away when
we get into spring and summer on the basis
of temperature and humidity without additional
intervention, like social distancing, finding
treatments, et cetera, is very, very low.
We're going to have to keep doing.
Of exhibiting behaviors that for a lot of
us aren't fun.
But it's just going
to have
to happen.
There's no way around it.